the movie is divided into four chapters
chapter one revelation we are introduced
to a woman named Elizabeth who lives in
the midwest with her husband Eli and
their two children the first one is
Matthew who is Eli's son from a previous
marriage and then there is Sam their
recently born daughter Elizabeth is a
mute woman who communicates through sign
language she works as a midwife and is
regarded to be excellent at delivering
babies probably because she can't hear
their annoying squeals oh wait no she's
mute not deaf I'm an idiot one day at
the local church a new preacher by the
name of Reverend shows up he talks about
false prophets and how they are
cancerous to society when Elizabeth
hears his voice she becomes scared it is
evident that she has a history with this
man later as the family is about to
leave a woman named Abigail suddenly
goes into labor Elizabeth takes her
inside the church and helps with the
delivery process unfortunately she
realizes that the baby is abnormal so it
is impossible to take it out without
harming the mother this means that one
one of them will have to go after a lot
of consideration Elizabeth secretly
euthanizes the baby hence saving
Abigail's life when they reach home Eli
consoles his wife saying that what
happened earlier was not her fault in
response she says it was the reverend's
fault however Eli dismisses her claims
as he believes the Reverend is a man of
God later Elizabeth heads to Abigail's
house to check on her however the
woman's husband Nathan stops her saying
the Reverend has already arranged a
doctor for them that night he gets
excess mely drunk and arrives outside
Elizabeth's house with a gun he shoots
aimlessly while shouting that she killed
his son Eli tries his best to calm him
down but to no avail after a while the
Reverend shows up and sends Nathan away
when Elizabeth notices him she
desperately tells her husband to not let
him in but Eli does anyway the two men
then have a weird conversation while
Elizabeth listens in from the other room
judging by her expression she appears to
be terrified of the man meanwhile the
Reverend tells Eli that his wife has
committed committed a sin as she decided
who was to live and who was to pass he
says that she will be punished for this
he then asks Elizabeth to come on now
but she is too scared for that thus the
Reverend leaves but not before promising
to return as soon as he departs
Elizabeth pleads with her husband that
they have to leave town this time Eli
understands that the man is dangerous so
he agrees he promises that they will go
to his father's house in a few days by
that time he will try to sell his sheep
unfortunately the next morning when
Matthew goes inside the barn he is met
with a gruesome sight all the sheep have
been slaughtered mercilessly Eli assumes
that this is Nathan's doing so he and
Matthew immediately grab his guns and
set off to confront him meanwhile
Elizabeth blindfolds her daughter as she
doesn't want the little girl to witness
the bloody situation she then goes
inside the barn to clean up the mess but
just then someone locks the door from
outside when Elizabeth Peaks through a
hole she is terrified to see the
Reverend taking her daughter away she
desperately calls for help but no one
one is around to listen to her when she
tries to climb up the door she slips and
Falls resulting in her passing out when
Elizabeth wakes up the door is open and
Eli has returned he reveals that he went
to Nathan's residence but learned that
the couple had already moved to another
city the previous night this makes it
impossible for Nathan to be the culprit
as the two are talking Sam suddenly
shows up bringing relief to the parents
that night while Elizabeth is tucking
her daughter into bed the latter asks
her a very weird question she inquires
if her mom is about person hearing this
Elizabeth realizes that the Reverend
brainwashed her daughter so in a fit of
rage she decides to murder him at his
house that'll show him who's a bad
person she grabs a knife gets on her
house and travels across the lonely town
in the middle of the night however when
she reaches the house she only finds her
daughter's doll on his bed on the other
hand we learn the Reverend has
infiltrated her house he is currently
lurking above a sleeping Sam at the same
time Eli jolts awake from his sleep and
realizes that his wife is missing when
he looks around he notices something a
Miss in the barn so he decides to check
it out Eli grabs his shotgun and heads
there but as soon as he opens the door
the Reverend stabs him multiple times
when Elizabeth returns she finds her
husband still alive but his guts are
protruding out of his stomach with his
final breath he asks his son Matthew to
take the family to his grandfather's
Farm the boy then grabs a gun and mercy
kills his father holy at the same
time Elizabeth realizes that the
Reverend is set fire to their house so
without wasting any time she takes the
kids and fleas the scene in their
Carriage chapter 2 Exodus we see a
13-year-old girl named Joanna wandering
through the deserts soon she passes out
due to severe dehydration a traveling
Chinese family finds her later and takes
her to the nearby town of bisou after
Joanna is nursed back to health she is
sold to the owner of a brothel named
Frank he appears to be a greedy and
dangerous individual who can go to any
lengths to please his customers as the
days pass by Joanna befriends one of the
escorts named Sally who takes good care
of her she explains the dos and don'ts
of the place and always protects her
from Evil Eyes one day a drunk customer
takes interest in Joanna but Sally
quickly persuades him to spend the night
with her the man accepts but only on the
condition that Joanna will watch them
later during the session the man gets
increasingly aggressive and starts
beating Sally up he then turns to Joanna
and this is when Sally makes the
difficult decision to shoot him dead as
a result of her actions she is publicly
hanged the next day don't worry I'm sure
this will end happily the scene then
cuts to several years later and we see
that Joanna has become an adult she is
now one of the popular escorts of the
brothel Joanna spends most of her time
with her best friend Elizabeth they
dream of escaping this wretched City one
day a man tries to harass Elizabeth and
she responds by biting his tongue
unfortunately this is a huge offense for
Frank and he punishes the poor woman by
cutting out her tongue this makes her
mute and she is now forced to
communicate in Sign Language regardless
this doesn't deter Elizabeth from her
dream of escaping the city and living a
peaceful life one day the two friends go
to a Matchmaker who mentions that a man
named Eli is willing to marry Elizabeth
he already has a son with his previous
wife Elizabeth promptly accepts the
offer and she asks Joanna to join her
the two friends then return to their
room and start packing but just as they
are about to leave a wealthy customer
buys all the escorts for the night he is
none other than the Reverend that night
despite having all the escorts to
himself he only calls Joanna to his room
he claims that he is beyond salvation
but he is here to save her as Joanna
stands there shivering he asks her to
own him he says that she has been
running away from him for too long and
now it's time she makes amends when
Joanna resists he starts assaulting her
mercilessly Elizabeth hears the
commotion from the other room so she
quickly arrives to help her friend
unfortunately the Reverend stabs her to
death he then proceeds to do the same to
Joanna but she manages to slash his
throat with the same knife after this
she dresses up Elizabeth as herself and
sets her body on fire later Joanna goes
to a doctor to get her tongue cut out
when he hesitates she does it herself
she then gets on a carriage and sets off
for Eli's home disguising herself as
Elizabeth chapter 3 Genesis we are taken
to a few years earlier in a surprising
turn of events the Reverend is revealed
to be none other than johanna's father
he is a dishonorable and wicked man who
regularly beats his wife Anna one day
Joanna spots blood on her clothes and
thinks that she is sick however her mom
makes her understand that this is very
normal for girls her age as the two are
chatting the Reverend spots them from a
distance and learns what's going on he
seems to have developed a weird
attraction towards his own daughter he
regularly stares at her and even makes
her clean him up when Anna notices this
she tells him that it's unethical
however he only responds by punishing
her even more one day Joanna finds two
injured men Jon and wolf out inside her
Barn they appear to be the remaining
survivors of a conflict seeing them so
desperate for help Joanna secretly hides
them inside her Barn she also feeds them
and gives them medicine to heal as the
days pass she develops a good
relationship with Jon however wolf only
tries to flirt with her Jon then reveals
to her that he and wolf are not friends
in fact the latter will not hesitate to
kill him when he gets fully well so Jon
hatches a plan and kills the man first
while he is taking a dump guys's got
luck in the meantime the Reverend
takes his wife to a blacksmith and
Designs a special instrument to cover
her mouth he says this is a punishment
for her actions this leaves poor Anna
feeling humiliated and she isn't even
allowed to speak from now on the
following day at the church while the
Reverend is giving one of his BS
speeches she suddenly commits the
unthinkable despite this the Reverend
doesn't feel bad for her and instead
says that she deserved it now that Anna
is out of the way he tries to force his
own daughter to marry him he even puts
the same metal instrument around her
face when she resists and screams for
help John arrives and confronts the
Reverend he tries to shoot him but the
ladder easily counters and shoots him
dead after this the Reverend drags his
daughter and whips her for befriending a
stranger when he gets tired and falls
asleep Joanna runs away from the house
chapter 4 retrobution this one begins
after the first one ended Joanna and her
children are riding through the snowy
terrain desperate to reach Eli's
father's house but unfortunately along
the way the Reverend catches up to them
and kills Matthew Joanna is shattered
but she doesn't have the time to mourn
so she continues on her way after a
while she finally reaches her
father-in-law's house and explains the
entire scenario to him the old man
breaks down in tears after learning that
his son and Grandson are dead
nonetheless he promises to keep little
Sam safe after a while Joanna grabs her
gun and decides to keep guard outside
she soon spots the reverend in the dark
and shoots at him but he appears to be
elusive he tries to intimidate her by
saying gruesome things from the dark he
also says says that she made a mistake
by leaving her daughter alone hearing
this Joanna rushes inside the house only
to find her father-in-law dead terrified
she tries to escape with her daughter
but the evil Reverend captures them in
the next scene we see that the two have
been tied to separate poles the Reverend
approaches Sam and whips her numerous
times as Joanna watches in horror he
claims that he is a man beyond salvation
so he can do anything he wants but just
as he is about to do something horrible
to the little girl Joanna breaks her arm
arms and sets herself free she then
grabs a lantern and throws it towards
her father setting him on fire now that
he is incapacitated Joanna shoots him at
Point Blank Range finally killing him
the scene then cuts to several months
later and we see that the mother and
daughter are living a peaceful life
Joanna has started a sawmill at her late
father-in-law's house some of her
relatives are helping her out in her
business unfortunately trouble once
again manages to find Joanna this time
in the form of Nathan one day he arrives
with his men revealing himself to be the
new sheriff in town he then displays a
poster of Elizabeth who is apparently
wanted for killing the brothel owner
Frank hearing this Joanna realizes that
during that fateful night Elizabeth had
actually killed Frank before coming to
her aid but since she has already taken
the identity of that woman she is unable
to defend herself poor Joan is then
arrested and taken away in a ship as she
sails away she notices Sam happily
planed with one of her relatives this
provides her with some relief as the
Reverend is no longer around to torment
her daughter Joanna then takes one final
look at Sam before committing the
unthinkable several years later we see
that Sam has grown into a woman she has
a daughter of her own and runs the
Sawmill despite losing her mother at an
early age she says that she can still
feel her around subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to to help the channel
out thank you for watching